collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je rappelle cette fois encore que
l'auteur de la question
de même que le ou la ministre dispose
pour la réponse chacun de deux minutes
trente merci de bien vouloir respecter
cette règle la parole est à monsieur
jean jacques lasserre pour le groupe
union des démocrates indépendants
indépendant us et ça marche oui monsieur
le monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à vous monsieur le ministre du
redressement productif
je me permets d'attirer votre attention
sur un sujet très préoccupant pour notre
région notre département les pyrénées
atlantiques
je parle de la cession par le groupe
total de sa filière transport
infrastructures gaz de france dit des
ige fdf dont le siège est basé à pau
employant actuellement près de 500
salariés dans le grand sud-ouest a pour
activité principale le transport et le
stockage du gaz naturel
cette activité est clairement porté
depuis des décennies par la société mère
total
au delà de son activité dans
l'exploration production depuis quelques
semaines total a manifesté sa volonté de
se séparer de sa filiale t jf prétextant
les nouvelles conditions du marché
européen et particulièrement le plan de
réorganisation du transport de gaz
engagé en europe énoncés notamment dans
la directive du 13 juillet 2009 et
transposé dans le code de l'énergie
français aux articles l 211 21 et
suivant qui rend obligatoire
l'indépendance des gestionnaires de
réseaux gaziers vis-à-vis des
producteurs
or le motif invoqué par total ne
semblent pas fondées puisque la société
thijs gf a reçu la certification de la
commission de régulation de l'énergie en
janvier dernier sous réserve de quelques
modifications qui sont déjà en cours
ce qui signifie qu'elle est conforme à
la directive européenne ou qu'elle
pourrait l'être très rapidement sa
volonté d'indépendance est clair est
déjà en cours de mise en oeuvre dans les
faits
ainsi face à cette situation jugée
inacceptable
les syndicats les salariés les élus
locaux n'ont pas tardé à réagir
les revendications et manifestations se
succèdent depuis cet été car ce sont des
centaines d'emplois qui peuvent être mis
en péril pour notre département des
pyrénées atlantiques
nous attendons de la part d'un géant du
pétrole du pétrole comme total qui leur
exposé un plan de reprise claire avec
des garanties concernant leur emploi et
leur savoir faire
par ailleurs le groupe total considère
que la territorialité d'intervention de
tjf est actuellement insuffisante
il est donc probable que le repreneur
est une aire d'intervention beaucoup
plus vaste se poseront alors évidemment
les questions consécutive à tout
regroupement restructuration
rationalisation des moyens et peut avoir
des conséquences de fortes
interrogations sur l'emploi de plus peut
se poser la question de la pertinence
d'un abandon de responsabilité d'une
société française dans un domaine aussi
stratégique que celui du transport et du
stockage du gaz naturel
monsieur le ministre je vous demande
d'en face à cette menace de cession qui
pénaliserait lourdement l'industrie
berlin et risquerait de toucher des
centaines d'emplois face au silence du
gouvernement depuis cet été ce qu'il
projette de faire en fait au regard des
nombreuses problématiques liées à ce
dossier énergétique de sécurité
industrielle et sociale
l'état doit jouer un rôle majeur et ne
peut rester spectateur je vous remercie
merci pour nous répondre la parole est à
monsieur arnaud montebourg ministre du
redressement productif
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jean jacques lasserre
vous évoquez en effet un dossier auquel
le gouvernement est très attentif et
qu'il surveille de près le dossier tei
gf quitte en effet une filiale à 100% de
total spécialisée dans le transport
stockage de gaz dont le siège social
vous avez raison de le signaler est
situé à pau emploie 500 personnes est
une entreprise par ailleurs extrêmement
rentable et qui fait l'objet aujourd'hui
d'une opération de abandon de la part de
total total souhaitant céder cet actif
pour procéder à des opérations de
désendettement
je dois vous indiquer comme élément de
réponse que le gouvernement est
particulièrement attentif au sort deux
pays gf que compte tenu de ses missions
et ses obligations de service public car
l'article l121 32 du code de l'énergie
le transport l'activité de transport et
de stockage de gaz obéit à des
obligations de service public qui amène
le gouvernement à ne pas se
désintéresser de cette session privée
est considéré que cette cession concerne
l'intérêt public et national
y at il des inquiétudes oui ils ont été
exprimées à plusieurs reprises par de
nombreux élus et pyrénées atlantiques
monsieur georges labazée qui est le
président du département madame espagnac
madame lignières cassou
monsieur habib ou madame chabane qui
nous ont saisis comme vous le faites
aujourd'hui monsieur la serre de façon
transparente izan de ses inquiétudes des
personnels qui se demande si des
opérations de défaisance de
restructuration auront lieu où en sommes
nous déjà du processus de cession c'est
le premier point de réponse depuis
vendredi dernier les lettres d'intention
ont été déposés par plusieurs
consortiums il y a plusieurs offres
françaises il ya des offres étrangères
il s'agit éventuellement au grosso modo
d'une session s'élevant jusqu'à
plusieurs milliards d'euros avec madame
delphine batho la ministre de l'énergie
nous sommes évidemment particulièrement
attentifs et souhaitons connaître les
intentions de total lorsque total se
sera exprimée auprès du gouvernement il
est évident que nous serons en mesure de
vous donner de plus amples informations
mais le gouvernement souhaite maintenir
et igf dans sa force sa rentabilité son
implantation et sa puissance est aussi
dans son niveau d'emploi cela est un
point important pour la région dont vous
êtes issu monsieur le sénateur merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à présent monsieur
françois rebsamen je suis le président
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
sur le président mesdames messieurs les
ministres
ce premier ministre ma question
s'adresse à vous l'article 24 de la
constitution
dispose que le sénat sur la
représentation des collectivités
territoriales de la république
c'est pourquoi nous savons touche sur
ses banques les collectivités locales
réalisent plus de 70% de
l'investissement public
après la déconfiture de dexia mais ce
premier ministre qui était leur
principal financeur les collectivités se
sont heurtés à des difficultés
croissantes pour accéder au crédit
cette situation vous en conviendrez est
un frein à la croissance et à l'emploi
certes le gouvernement a pris des
mesures d'urgence
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances l'a annoncé l'autre jour à
dijon notamment le déblocage d'une
enveloppe exceptionnelle de 5 milliards
d'euros en 2012 sur fond des pagnes de
la caisse des dépôts et consignations et
la banque postale a décidé de son côté
d'accorder des prêts aux collectivités
pour un montant de 3 milliards d'euros
mais ces enveloppes porte et nos
collègues le sarde sur des prêts de
court et de moyen terme
or les collectivités ont besoin
assurément de financer je vais dire dans
l'intérêt même de notre pays des
investissements structurants pour la
croissance et l'emploi de notre économie
des investissements structurants qui
nécessitent monsieur le premier ministre
des financements sur une durée parfois
supérieures à 20 ans alors ce premier
ministre ma question est assez simple le
gouvernement envisage-t-il des mesures
pour permettre ces investissements de
long terme et si oui lesquelles
merci de votre réponse merci la parole
est à monsieur jean marc ayrault premier
ministre ah merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président françois rebsamen
vous mettez l'accent sur un problème
très important pour la croissance et
l'emploi dans notre pays c'est la
question centrale aujourd'hui le 6
novembre j'ai annoncé le pacte pour la
évitez la croissance et l'emploi les
collectivités locales par leur
investissement et contribue fortement
elles ont engagé des investissements
très importants de proximité mais aussi
les investissements structurants vous
avez rappelé l'esprit mais aussi la
réalité de ce que représente dans notre
pays l'investissement des collectivités
territoriales plus de 70% de
l'investissement public c'est dire à
quel point surtout dans cette période
leur rôle est plus crucial que jamais la
question du financement
je les affronter dès ma prise de
fonction tous les élus et pas seulement
les rapports qui me remontait mais tout
ce que je rencontrais des collectivités
locales les plus grandes comme le plus
petit
m'alerter sur cette situation pour
l'essentiel la crise de financement en
investissement et en trésorerie des
collectivités territoriales était due à
la crise de dexia
je ne vais pas ici développé les causes
qui ont conduit à cette crise même si on
peut la qualifier de navrantes et le
président de la république devant le
congrès des maires de france l'a évoqué
brièvement en rappelant que l'ancienne
qu'avec l'ancien crédit local de france
a pris des décisions à une époque plus
qu aventureuse j'irai même irresponsable
dont on paye les conséquences
aujourd'hui puisque il faut empêcher la
faillite de dexia qui est maintenant une
banque franco-belge et que l'état belge
comme l'état français devront avec
l'argent des contribuables contribuer à
la facture et il faut rappeler la
responsabilité
effectivement de ce qu'ils ont prises
ces dernières années elle effectivement
lourde elle effectivement grave et elle
a des conséquences pour le financement
de l'investissement des collectivités
locales dont vous l'avez rappelé un
crédit d'urgence avec la caisse des
dépôts pour 2012 de 5 milliards
et puis la préparation puisque
maintenant un accord est intervenu avec
la belgique et qui fait l'objet d'une
négociation finale avec la commission
européenne pour prendre la suite de
dexia avec la future banque des
collectivités locales qui va s'appuyer
sur la banque postale avec le concours
de la caisse des dépôts et son travail a
déjà commencé
mais ça ne suffira pas c'est pour cela
que le gouvernement a pris deux
décisions que le président de la
république a évoqué dans son
intervention et qui sont extrêmement
concrètes
d'abord la levée de 20 milliards d'euros
20 milliards vous m'avez posé une
question précise je vous réponds à
partir des fonds d'épargné de la caisse
des dépôts 20 milliards pour les
investissements structurants et de long
terme des collectivités locales pour la
plupart plus de 20 ans ja concerne les
transports publics
ça concerne l'eau ça concerne
l'assainissement ça concerne aussi les
travaux dans les équipements publics en
particulier scolaire en matière
d'isolation thermique et ça concerne
aussi un chantier très important auquel
vous êtes très attaché et au sénat vous
en avez souvent parler puisque vous avez
même débattu de cela à travers une
proposition doit ce sont les
investissements qui sont aussi source de
compétitivité de croissance dans le
numérique pour accéder à sur tous les
territoires au haut débit donc ces
investissements seront financés
concernant le numérique je présenterai
dans quelques semaines un plan
d'ensemble
et puis enfin le gouvernement et le
président de la république l'a annoncé a
donné son accord pour que soit créée une
agence de financement des collectivités
locales c'est vrai que ce sont souvent
les plus grandes qui sont à l'origine de
ce projet pour lever des fonds sur les
marchés financiers que sans que pour
autant la garantie de l'état des
contribuables soient appelés mais ce
dossier a été mûrement réfléchie a été
expertisé il fait l'objet d'un consensus
les collectivités locales sont engagés
et le gouvernement et le président de la
république a annoncé à donner son accord
donc quand on fait l'addition de tous
ces dispositifs à la fois de court terme
à la fois de moyen terme et de long
terme
je crois que l'horizon pour le
financement des collectivités
territoriales s'est éclairci mais c'est
une nécessité c'est une question
d'intérêt général c'est le respect des
décisions des élus de ces toutes ces
collectivités territoriales et vous
l'avez rappelé à juste titre monsieur le
président françois rebsamen
mais c'est aussi un plus pour la
croissance et l'emploi
merci monsieur joël labbé pour le groupe
écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames les ministres messieurs les
ministres mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
monsieur stéphane le foll elle concerne
la santé des abeilles
la surmortalité des abeilles et
l'effondrement des colonies sont des
phénomènes très préoccupant que l'on
observe à l'échelle nationale et aussi à
l'échelle de la planète
certaines familles de pesticides les
néonicotinoïdes et les faits ni le pire
azoles sont clairement mis en cause par
de nombreuses études
il relève d'une classe d'insecticides
agite agissant sur le système nerveux
central des insectes
ce type de pesticides dit systémique est
présent sur le marché de l'agrochimie
depuis 1994
ces études démontrent la très forte
toxicité du traitement des semences par
enrobage des graines ce traitement
entraîne un effet dit à haute
persistance c'est à dire que le
pesticide est diffusée dans toute la
plante et cela tout au long de sa vie
cependant il est à noter que la plupart
des études qui servent de base aux
délivrance des autorisations de mise sur
le marché se concentre sur les doses
létales de pesticides or des doses non
létales souvent faibles peuvent avoir
des conséquences catastrophiques pour
les abeilles les faits l'état les temps
alors indirects c'est ce qu'a prouvé
l'étude française publiée dans la revue
science le 29 mars 2012 la capacité de
retour à la ruche est affecté et ainsi
il a été constaté une surmortalité très
importante des abeilles alors même
qu'elles sont exposés à une dose
pourtant cinq fois inférieure aux doses
considéré comme mortel
l'évaluation des risques des pesticides
doit donc nécessairement
systématiquement prendre en compte les
effets létaux en direct dans le calcul
de l'impact sur les pollinisateurs ainsi
que la toxicité chronique larvaires et
sublétale le 23 mai 2012
l'efsa a publié un avis scientifique sur
la manière dont les pesticides devrait
être évalué quant à leur impact sur les
sur les abeilles
cette analyse démontre que les
pesticides de la famille des
néonicotinoïdes et définit le pire
azoles n'ont jamais été correctement
évalué et que par conséquent les
autorisations de mise sur le marché
l'ont été sur la base d'évaluations 0
n'est l'abeille est un vecteur de
pollinisation indispensable à la
biodiversité
elle joue un rôle écologique primordial
pour la sécurité alimentaire et revêtent
un enjeu économique majeur
sa valeur a d'ailleurs été chiffré à 150
milliards de dollars par an mais encore
bien au delà de ces chiffres la bei
nous adultes est l'utilité irremplaçable
que si elle venait à disparaître de la
planète
l'homme n'aurait plus que quelques
années à vivre comme l'a proclamé
monsieur albert einstein qui est est lui
à la fois autant scientifique que
philosophe au posé la question et finir
rapidement si madame monsieur le
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture
dans la tente d'une réévaluation
complète des néo nicotine
id est défini le pire à sal selon les
nouvelles lignes directrices de l'efs ça
comptez-vous suspendre les autorisations
de mise sur le marché de ses produits en
france à commencer par le couvert sur
les maïs et ce afin de préserver les
abeilles merci merci chers collègues je
sais prendre votre attention
je stéphane le foll ministre de
l'agriculture agro alimentaire de la
souris ce président est monsieur les
sénateurs monsieur l'abbé j'ai fait
comprendre qu au début de votre question
il ya eu un murmure dans cette assemblée
silencieuse d'habitude pour saluer le
sujet que vous évoquez celui des
abeilles
il est vrai que les abeilles sont dans
la nature
un outil précieux vous l'avait dit pour
la pollinisation et il faut tout faire
pour préserver ce rôle-là j'indiquerai
d'ailleurs que la france au passage est
un pays qui consomme 40 mille tonnes de
miel et quand produit 18 mille tonnes
elle en importe seize mille tonnes qui
prenait en particulier de la chine
pasteurisé et filtrer j'invite donc
chacun à mesurer l'effort que nous
devons faire pour la production de miel
en france le ministre de l'agriculture a
pris des décisions et il y aura un plan
stratégique qui sera présenté en début
d'année prochaine
justement pour développer à la fois la
production de miel et surtout les
protections qui doivent être données aux
abeilles vous avez évoqué la famille des
néonicotinoïdes sujet que j'ai dû
traiter à peine arrivé au ministère de
l'agriculture après cette étude du
magazine science qui a été confirmé par
la vie de l'ansès et qui m'a conduit à
interdire le cruiser sur le colza
famille des décos des néonicotinoïdes ça
m'a permis d'ailleurs à l'échelle
européenne d'engager une discussion avec
le commissaire de l'époque monsieur dali
pour que l'efsa à l'échelle européenne
fasse aussi une étude sur l'ensemble de
cette famille compte
des conséquences qui avait été mesuré
sur le cruiser colza fleurs ecti faire
et la possibilité qu'il y ait à ce
moment là des conséquences sur d'autres
plantes pour les abeilles
la mortalité vous ne l'avez dit d abel
est lié aujourd'hui tout le monde est
d'accord à des phénomènes
multifactorielle n'a pas qu'un seul
facteur et l'effort que nous devons
faire sur les phytosanitaires et le
recours aux phytosanitaires
indépendamment de la question des
abeilles est un effort que nous allons
conduire pour réduire les recours
globaux au phyto sanitaires quelles que
soient les productions c'est un
engagement qui a été pris pour ce qui
est donc d'aider côté no id est la
question qui était posée si j'ai bien
compris à la fin malgré le brouhaha
est-ce que j'étais redirai ou y
aura-t-il un moratoire n'y aura pas de
moratoire tant que je n'aurai pas des
résultats des études j'ai pris comme
principe ça a été le cas d'ailleurs pour
l'étude séralini comme celle pour le
cruiser d'avoir des décisions rapides à
partir du moment où j'ai les résultats
scientifiques qui me sont fournis
j'attendrai donc les résultats d'edf sa
je pousse au niveau de la commission
pour que cette étude soit faite et qu'on
ne donne des résultats
parce que dans un certain nombre des
pays des décisions ont été prises selon
les cas sur le maïs sur le colza
nous avons besoin d'harmoniser notre
position à l'échelle européenne
sachez que le ministre de l'agriculture
tient aux abeilles merci merci
leur survie chamayou pour le groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères pendant plusieurs jours la
population de la bande de gaza a été
soumise à d'intenses bombardements de
l'aviation israélienne en représailles
aux tirs de roquettes pratiqué par le
hamas et d'autres groupes armés
cette brute à l'exacerbation du conflit
israélo palestinien
les tirs de roquettes d'un côté usage
disproportionné de la force par le
gouvernement israélien de l'autre ont
déjà causé la mort de cinq israéliens et
255 palestiniens principalement des
civils dont des femmes et des enfants
l'attentât qui a eu lieu hier à tel aviv
et que je condamne aussi montre bien les
risques d'un engrenage
ce n'est pas la violence qui assurera la
sécurité d'israël ni la paix dans la
région
un fragile accord de cessez-le-feu a été
trouvé hier c'est une très bonne
nouvelle
monsieur le ministre je sais tous les
efforts diplomatiques que vous avez
déployés pour contribuer à cette trêve
en vous rendant sur place la semaine
dernière et en rencontrant les
différents protagonistes engagés dans
des pourparlers indirects dans
lesquelles l'egypte joue d'ailleurs un
rôle essentiel est qu'il faut également
saluer mais il ne rêve n'est pas la paix
elle ne serait réglé le fond du problème
le blocus de gaza est maintenu la
colonisation de la cisjordanie de
jérusalem-est par le gouvernement
israélien se poursuit au mépris de
nombreuses résolutions de l'onu restée
sans effet car au delà de ces événements
dramatiques triste répétition de ce que
l'on a déjà connu il y a quelques années
avec l'opération plomb durci on peut
supposer que cet enchaînement de
provocations et de répression n'a
d'autre but que de torpiller une
solution à deux états reconnu par la
communauté internationale
il s'agit là d'un point sur lequel le
hamas et le gouvernement israéliens sont
en parfait accord
et pourtant désormais la seule voie pour
mettre fin à ce conflit de plusieurs
décennies une solution fondée sur la
sécurité d'israël et le droit des
palestiniens à disposer d'un état dans
les frontières de 1967
c'est tout le sens de l'initiative que
prendra l'autorité palestinienne le 29
novembre prochain lorsque le président
mahmoud abbas présentera une résolution
devant l'assemblée générale des nations
unies tendance à accorder à la palestine
le statut symbolique d'état non membre
d'où ma question monsieur le ministre le
face à face auquel la communauté
internationale a contraint les
palestiniens et les israéliens appelés
processus de paix a totalement échoué
désormais seule une reconnaissance
internationale d'un état palestinien
permettrait d'avancer dans le règlement
de ce conflit
en reprenant les négociations dans un
nouveau cadre
pouvez vous me préciser la position
qu'adoptera la france lors du vote de
cette résolution
au moment où selon un sondage une grande
majorité de français souhaite que paris
soutiennent l'initiative palestinienne
je vous remercie pour vous répondre
monsieur laurent fabius ministre des
affaires étrangères c'est le président
du sénat
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur d'abord il faut
comme vous l'avez fait salué la bonne
nouvelle que représente le cessez le feu
qui est intervenu hier en fin d'après
midi entre israël et le hamas
j'ai eu l'occasion d'avoir au téléphone
ce matin mais mon collègue mais les
affaires de gip siens et j'ai salué
l'importance de la contribution de
l'egypte dans
ce qui n'est qu'un cessez le feu mais ce
qui est fait et j'ai pris contact avec
nos partenaires israéliens pour
approuver aussi puisque j'avais eu
l'occasion de rencontrer dimanche le
geste qui a été fait par israël c'est
une bonne nouvelle et en même temps vous
l'avez souligné
c'est une nouvelle fragile d'abord parce
que à partir des heures qui viennent
d'autres discussions s'engagent du côté
israélien il y à la demande légitime que
bien sûr les tirs de roquettes ne
reprennent pas et qu' on est vite c'est
la responsabilité de l'egypte et qu'il y
ait de nouveaux afflux d'armes et il
faudra que l'egypte contrôle pas
seulement ce qui est fait par le masque
de l'ensemble des groupes et
symétriquement il est demandé qu'il y
ait un desserrement du blocus et donc ce
sont les discussions qui sont devant
nous et la france a dit à ses
partenaires qu'elle était disponible si
on pouvait aider
voilà où nous en sommes maintenant vous
poser la question plus générale de la
paix et vous poser la question de la
résolution qui probablement va être
déposée dans les jours qui viennent et
qui si elle est déposée devrait faire
l'objet d'un vote jeudi prochain on peut
discuter sur l'opportunité à cet instant
de déposer une résolution mais si elle
est déposée il faudra bien que nous nous
prononcions nous sommes en discussion
avec bien sûr les palestiniens nous
sommes en discussion avec nos
partenaires européens
je puis vous indiquer une direction qui
est celle d'ailleurs qui a été prise à
la fois depuis très longtemps par les
principaux partis politiques français
lors du gouvernement précédent lorsque
à propos de la question de savoir si la
palestine devait rentrer à l'unesco
c'est un vote favorable qui avait été
fait et en ce qui concerne le
gouvernement actuel je veux rappeler que
l'engagement numéro 59 du candidat
devenu président françois hollande dit
qu'il y aura reconnaissance
internationale de l'état palestinien
voilà où nous en sommes voilà l'état des
discussions ce dont il s'agit mais
l'année messieurs les sénateurs c'est de
réaffirmer la position de la france la
france est l'amie d'israël et du peuple
palestinien la cause qu'elle défend et
celle de la paix laquelle implique la
sécurité d'israël et le droit des
palestiniens à disposer d'un état viable
démocratique pacifique
merci merci monsieur robert tropéano
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique social européen
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'égalité des territoires et
du logement
madame la ministre suit en alternance et
à notre victoire collective du mois de
mai et juin dernier le président de la
république et son premier ministre ont
pris la décision de créer un ministère
de l'égalité des territoires ministère
dont vous avez la charge par cette
décision a été reconnue admise l'urgence
qu'il ya à lutter contre l'accroissement
quasi ininterrompu des inégalités
territoriales dans notre pays depuis
maintenant plusieurs décennies et sous
différentes majorités
car l'enjeu mes chers collègues dépasse
bien évidemment les clivages politiques
il s'agit tout simplement de l'unité de
la république à laquelle nous sommes
tous ici très attaché et pour cause
puisque notre assemblée conformément à
l'article 24 de la constitution assure
la représentation des collectivités
territoriales de la république
et n'en déplaise à certains qui
voudraient voir le sénat coupé des
réalités locales et des difficultés
quotidiennes des territoires un perdant
ainsi sa vocation première
inhérente
c'est ce même du bicamérisme notre pays
qu'on est aujourd'hui une fracture
territoriale fracture territoriale qui
nourrit et aggrave une longue série
d'inégalité entre les citoyens
inégalités dans l'accès aux services
publics au logement à la santé à
l'emploi à la culture inégalités
scolaires en matière de transports ou
encore de haut débit les dégâts de la
bad dont d'une véritable politique
d'aménagement du territoire sont
désormais visibles dans nombre de
bas-lieu fragiles mais aussi dans bien
des territoires ruraux et plus grave
encore ces inégalités ne font que
s'accroître si bien que les territoires
riches bien équipé et bien desservir
sont toujours mieux lotis et les
territoires les plus pauvres sont de
plus en plus pauvres subissant même une
double peine puisqu'ils doivent
supporter plus lourdement le poids de
l'impôt local
l'insuffisance des dispositifs actuels
de péréquation est avérée elle a été
maintes fois dénoncée notamment par
plusieurs travaux du sénat
il est temps d'enrayer cette spirale
infernale et de lutter contre cette
fracture territoriale qui mine les
fondements du pacte républicain
alors madame la ministre ma question est
simple
quelles sont les intentions du
gouvernement en la matière allez vous
répondre
restaurer une politique volontaire
d'aménagement du territoire
comment entendez-vous développer une
politique ambitieuse pour que l'égalité
des territoires dont vous avez la charge
re devienne une réalité merci madame
cécile duflot ministre de l'égalité des
territoires et du logement
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur vous avez raison de pointer la
nouveauté que constitue ce ministère de
l'égalité des territoires et vous avez
raison d'indiquer que ce que nous avons
vécu dans notre pays depuis 10 15 ans
après une époque d'aménagement du
territoire extrêmement volontariste voir
dirigiste voire même dans certains cas
un peu autoritaire a été une sorte de
laisser faire en privilégiant une
intervention sur quelques territoires
considérant que les rides territoires
les moins favorisés pourrait
bénéficier de cette intervention
volontary sur quelques territoires
ce n'est pas le résultat auquel nous
avons pu constater puisque si l'égalité
entre les grandes régions c'est plutôt a
plutôt augmenté les inégalités au sein
des territoires se sont accrues et 6 85%
de la population vit en ville
aujourd'hui 70% du territoire français
est un espace rural donc nous ne pouvons
accepter de laisser perdurer cette
fracture voire même de la voir
s'accroître c'est pourquoi au-delà de
cette conviction qui est celle du
gouvernement et qui est bien évidemment
la mienne nous avons une ambition celle
de faire en sorte que toutes les
politiques publiques passe désormais au
filtre de cet objectif d'égalité des
territoires en particulier dans cette
période difficile et exigeante de
redressement des finances publiques mais
nous avons des objectifs aussi très
clair et notamment pour répondre à ce
que vous avez pointé en matière de
services publics en nous appuyant sur
initiative qui a été porté dans 22
départements par la datar l'initiative
plus de services au public de mettre en
place un dispositif qui permet d'appuyer
le travail et la cartographie des
services publics sur le territoire bien
plus que par une vision vertical cette
question de l'accès aux services publics
est absolument déterminante pour lutter
contre le sentiment d'isolement voire
même de relégation que peuvent ressentir
une partie des habitants de nos pays en
zone rurale en zone hyper rural voire
même dans certains quartiers urbains
lutter contre l'isolément c'est aussi
travailler de manière très active en
faveur de l'aménagement numérique
l'aménagement numérique outil décisif
essentiel l'ambition énoncé par un
président de la république est très
forte
nous travaillons à faire en sorte que
cette fracture numérique disparaissent
se résorbe dans les cinq années qui
viennent et enfin une méthode cette
méthode c'est celle de la consultation
c'est celle de la concertation avec les
élus mais aussi avec cette commission
pour la mise en place d'un commissariat
général à l'égalité des territoires qui
trente ans après le début de la
décentralisation doit penser
différemment les relations entre l'état
et les collectivités locales sur la base
d'une volonté d'égalité des territoires
d'une vraie contractualisation plus près
des territoires
en reconnaissant leur spécificité voilà
monsieur le sénateur l'ambition qui est
grande la méthode qui j'espère vous
satisfera du gouvernement en matière
d'égalité des territoires
merci monsieur françois noël buffet pour
le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres ma question
était à l'attention du premier ministre
le président de la république s'est
engagé à l'occasion de la campagne
électorale à l'autorisation du mariage
homosexuel
il y a quelques semaines le conseil des
ministres en acté le principe cette
décision incontestablement a suscité des
réactions de tous bords de toute nature
singulièrement cent mille manifestants
ce week end dernier 17 mille officiers
d'état civil de tous les bords
politiques se sont émus de ce texte aux
courses à l'occasion du congrès des
maires qui vient de se dérouler mardi
dernier le président de la république
dans son intervention un fait état d'une
clause de conscience possible pour les
mères sans doute conscient lui même que
le sujet posait problème dans tous les
cas ouvrait le débat proposant qu'
effectivement les maires puissent ne pas
célébrer à son la demande et à leurs
adjoints ou un de leurs membres du
conseil municipal de le faire de deux
choses l'une soit il ne sait pas que
c'est déjà possible soit il est
effectivement pas convaincu de la
proposition et cherche une porte de
sortie
et puis et puis nous apprenons hier et
dans la presse ce matin
rétropédalage non non non non non du
tout pas de problème de clause de
conscience
le texte sera présenté tel qu'il doit
l'être et pas de changement particulier
incontestablement le président a posé ce
texte sur le plan de la morale et il a
de ce fait peut être réseau ou je ne
sais pas en tous les cas il a posé cette
question là et il est incontestable que
les réactions importantes qui se sont
présentés ces dernières semaines faut
que la question et le débat doit être
ouvert au plan national mais dans des
conditions organisé ce que nous
demandons aujourd'hui madame le ministre
je pense que c'est vous qui allez me
répondre c'est d'abord quelle est la
position claire et nette du gouvernement
et du président de la république sur ce
texte et ensuite nous vous demandons de
retirer ce texte est d'organiser comme
ça a été le cas sur des grands sujets
comme la bioéthique notamment un grand
débat national afin qu'il y ait une
discussion ouverte et clair avant que
sur un sujet de société aussi important
les parlementaires et à se prononcer
merci à notre sens taubira garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur buffet le premier
ministre dont vous savez le respect
qu'il a toujours montré aux élus et aux
parlementaires en particulier vous prie
de l'excuser
il a dû se rendre à une autre contrainte
je vais répondre à votre question il
non non ça n'est pas à une contrainte et
la faute mais totalement imputable le
sujet que vous évoquez n'est pas un
sujet de morale monsieur le sénateur et
dans cette haute assemblée
il vous est aisé de concevoir il s'agit
d'un sujet de droit et d'un engagement
sur l'égalité un engagement que le
président de la république a porté sans
la moindre ambiguïté pendant toute sa
campagne et il a souhaité que le
gouvernement met en oeuvre cet
engagement très vite de sorte qu'avec la
ministre chargée de la famille dominique
bertinotti
nous avons été chargé d'engager les
auditions de façon à construire le temps
ex avec la rigueur qu'on tend notre code
civil vous avez cité le président de la
république avec une exacte
une inexactitude qui n'a échappé à
personne
vous êtes ici la haute assemblée c'est à
dire la chambre des collectivités vous
connaissez d'une façon générale
l'attachement des mères à l'exercice de
leurs prérogatives et en particulier
lorsqu'ils agissent en qualité
d'officier d'état civil en qualité
d'agent public et qu'au nom de l'état il
célèbre des mariages il s'agira si les
deux chambres vote cette réforme d'un
texte de loi qui s'appliquera sur
l'ensemble du territoire
les textes de notre droit actuel seront
appliquées à ces mariages à droit
constant
l'institution du mariage est donc ouvert
aux couples de même sexe et l'adoption
comporte le mariage leur sera ouverte
dans les conditions prévues actuellement
par le code civil
il n'y a donc aucune ambiguïté il n'y a
aucune intention de retrait du texte
le débat a lieu dans la société il y a
eu lieu pendant il a eu lieu pendant la
campagne électorale où le président de
la république candidat à porter sans
ambiguïté cet engagement il y a
d'ailleurs des personnes qui ont choisi
de ne pas voter pour lui parce que cet
engagement était parfaitement assumé par
le candidat
quant au maire nous n'avons aucune
inquiétude nous connaissons leur esprit
républicain que quelques uns s'exprime
c'est leur liberté ils connaissent le
droit ils ont connaissent la rigueur et
ils choisissent selon leur totale
liberté de s'y opposer et d'en assumer
éventuellement les conséquences mais
nous sommes tranquilles nous savons que
la grande majorité des maires vont se
conformer au droit pas me le font
aujourd'hui déjà et nous avons entendu y
compris dans vos rangs de plus en plus
de mères qui
assume d'assurer la continuité du
service public sur l'intégralité du
territoire de respecter l'égalité des
droits et par conséquent d'agir forêts
publiques
la parole est un monsieur j'en attendais
chili pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés merci monsieur le président
mes chers collègues messieurs mesdames
et messieurs les ministres monsieur le
ministre ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre du redressement
productif
elle concerne l'avenir des hauts
fourneaux de florange
mais à travers cet avenir monsieur le
ministre il en va aussi de l'avenir
notre industrie l'aude
car comme vous le savez florange est
devenu un symbole de la
désindustrialisation et de ses ravages
pour la france entière avec petroplus
voilà deux noms qui incarne aux yeux des
salariés mais aussi de nos concitoyens
que pour certains seule la course au
profit des dirigeants des actionnaires
compte au détriment des emplois et de
notre industrie au préalable monsieur le
ministre pour avoir été en contact
régulier avec vous comme mon collègue
michel liebgott et ma collègue sénatrice
gisèle prise je voudrais saluer votre
engagement votre disponibilité sur ce
dossier de florange afin d'aboutir à la
meilleure solution possible pour
l'avenir de notre sidérurgie et de notre
industrie lourde à l'assemblée nationale
hier le seul ministre vous avez déclaré
que deux offres de reprise du site
d'arcelormittal florange été fait mais
sur un périmètre plus large que celui
que ce monsieur mittal entend céder un
peu connaisseur du dossier
j'en déduis que les éventuels repreneurs
ne souhaite pas et à juste titre la
coupure de la filière chaude et de la
filière froide ce qui serait
effectivement un non sens industriel
mais aussi économiques
le rapport qui nous a remis monsieur
faure faisait la démonstration que le
site de florange avait un avenir certain
avec une production d'acier de qualité
et des principaux clients qui sont
situés encore plus à l'est que la
lorraine dont on tour plus des lieux
éloignés du site de dunkerque
dunkerque là même où malgré les
déclarations du groupe arcelormittal un
haut fourneau de redémarrera pas dans
l'immédiat en lorraine
nous savons monsieur le ministre ce que
valent les engagements de monsieur
mittal surtout à gandrange
mais nous savons aussi ce que sont
devenues les promesses du précédent
présente président de la république
monsieur nicolas sarkozy
le seul ministre il ne serait pas
acceptable qu'on présence le repreneur
sérieux monsieur vital puisse dicter sa
loi sur l'avenir de notre industrie de
notre production d'acier face à cette
mondialisation
je sais les efforts que fait le
gouvernement pour la compétitivité de
notre industrie mais n'est-il pas temps
d'envoyer un message fort à l'europe sur
le sujet et plus largement d'envoyer un
signal fort de la volonté politique du
gouvernement de sauvegarder l'industrie
lourde et ses milliers d'emplois dans
notre pays
comment le gouvernement peut-il d'ici le
1er décembre amené monsieur mittal à
assumer ses responsabilités et l'amener
à modifier le périmètre de cession
dans le cas contraire n'est-il pas temps
d'écrire le changement et de se donner
des moyens législatifs face à la famille
mittal de pérenniser la production
d'acier français et les hauts fourneaux
de florange et pourquoi pas s'il le
fallait
d'aller vers une prise de contrôle
public de l' usine de florange
il en va de la crédibilité de l'action
engagée par le gouvernement qui
courageusement fait face sur tous les
fronts ce serait un signal fort des
perspectives claires pour définir une
stratégie de rebond industriel
cela serait-il post sera-t-il possible
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur arnaud montebourg
ministre lui redressement productif
chez le président du sénat monsieur le
sénateur de la moselle jean marc
todeschini
j'ai en effet déclaré hier à l'assemblée
nationale que le gouvernement et mon
ministère avait reçu deux offres de
d'entrepreneurs dans le détail desquels
je ne peux entrer en raison de la
confidentialité que ces industriels ont
demandé au gouvernement français
1 ce matin la firme arcelormittal a
déclaré n'avoir pas connaissance de ces
offres
cela est tout à fait normal car ce sont
des offres qui ont été exprimés auprès
de l'autorité politique et non pas
d'arcelormittal dans la mesure où ce
sont des offres qui concerne un
périmètre plus large que celui qui a
octroyé à la reprise arcelormittal
c'est la première démonstration
d'ailleurs de ce que finalement le
problème des hauts fourneaux de florange
ce n'est pas la défaillance des hauts
fourneaux de florange
c'est la défaillance de mittal je veux
rappeler que mittal est propriétaire de
25 hauts fourneaux en europe disposant
de part de marché quasi monopolistique
et que ceux-ci arcelormittal a décidé
ont décidé d'enfermer 9 à liège
aujourd'hui se déroule le même scénario
qu'à florange et je veux faire observer
que ce qui nous avait été dit sur
dunkerque il ne risquait rien
aujourd'hui fait l'objet de premières
mesures de préparation à la fermeture
les gouvernements européens que j'ai
pris la peine d'aller rencontrer le
luxembourg la belgique en ont assez
d'être mené par le bout du nez par
arcelormittal et nous retrouvons
finalement ce qui s'est passé en 2006
lorsqu'il lui une opa hostile sans aucun
plan stratégique sur la totalité de
l'acier qui a appartenu à tous les
citoyens européens
je rappelle que des gouvernements
européens ont dû nationaliser dans
l'histoire leur acier c'était le cas
d'ailleurs en france de raymond barre ce
fut le cas également au luxembourg en
belgique et que c'est par des efforts
considérables des contribuables de tous
les états européens que cet acier a pu
être performant compétitif une op et
qu'une au pea et style da la famille
mittal est venu finalement placé entre
des mains disposant de centres de
décisions qui n'ont rien à voir avec les
intérêts
sionneau de ces états européens je veux
aussi dire que tous les engagements que
j'ai fait exhumer par les services à
l'époque de l'opéra hostile vis-à-vis de
la france
pris par mittal n'ont jamais étaient
respectées je veux d'ailleurs dire que
dans une convention d'ancrage
territorial signés en 2009 le groupe
arcelormittal prévoit y est je cite
entre guillemets d'inscrire dans ses
plans d'investissements la réfection de
deux hauts fourneaux dans une période
2013 à 2015 ce sont ceux là mêmes qu'il
est en train aujourd'hui de fermer
je veux aussi ajouté que le groupe
arcelormittal fait un usage assez
immodéré aux yeux du gouvernement
français mais aussi du gouvernement
luxembourgeois e2 des quotas de co2 et
notamment d'un certain nombre d' aides
publiques
je veux aussi également précisé à au
sénateur qui ici ne m'écoute et j'espère
que cette information ira au delà de
cette enceinte et qu'elle sera entendue
ailleurs que mittal aujourd'hui est
redevable aux yeux de l'administration
fiscale française d'une dette fiscale
que nous considérons comme astronomiques
et nous pouvons aujourd'hui considéré
que la question que la question qui est
posée par vous monsieur le sénateur de
la moselle de l'éventualité d'un
contrôle public même temporaire doit
faire l'objet d'une étude sérieuse par
le gouvernement et c'est le cas de ce à
quoi nous nous sommes attelés depuis
plusieurs mois si monsieur
monsieur louis pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur si j'en crois un journal du
matin la situation de la sécurité dans
notre pays continue de s'aggraver
c'est ainsi que le mois dernier les
violences à l'égard des personnes
augmenté de 9% et même 24% en faisant de
gendarmerie de même les cambriolages et
autres vols soit presque 190 milles
faits recensés ont cru dans le même
temps 2 8%
les effraction de résidences principales
et secondaires augmenté de 16 % et enfin
la criminalité organisée
au delà des cas dramatiques et
médiatisée de ces dernières semaines a
augmenté elle aussi de 7%
toutes ces catégories de délits ou de
crimes que je viens de citer au pour
caractéristique d'avoir chaque collègue
pour victimes de ces actes des êtres
humains nos citoyens monsieur le
ministre
subissent ainsi de plein fouet l'impact
d'une délinquance qui non seulement ne
faiblit pas mais augmente
face à ce constat des plus préoccupants
nous proposons monsieur le ministre que
soit organisé un riposte
l'union sacrée de toutes les forces de
sécurité police nationale gendarmerie et
police municipale
cette dernière qualifiée par nicolas
sakozy de troisième force de sécurité de
la république avec ses dix-huit mille
agents doit accompagner doit accompagner
chers collègues de manière étroite et
complémentaires l'action des forces de
l'état aussi en plein congrès des maires
vous monsieur le ministre qui avait été
maire comme je le suis vous avez fait le
choix je reprends vos termes d'une
police municipale puissantes afin
d'utiliser tous les moyens mis à ma
disposition
aussi monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur je propose donc
que la police municipale cette police de
proximité sous l'autorité des maires
soit le plus étroitement possible
associés dans le domaine complémentaires
j insiste qui est le sien à la réaction
de l'état républicain face à la montée
de la délinquance et dispose donc
monsieur le ministre
en conséquence des moyens de cette
politique partenariale
je vous propose donc d'agir de manière
pragmatique dans un souci d'efficacité
de terrain je prendrais trois exemples
concrets qui peuvent se réaliser dans un
délai très court et sans entraîner une
dépense publique bien le contraire accès
direct aux fichiers confirmé la
possibilité des contrôles préalables et
interconnexion des radios transmission
ma question est donc simple monsieur le
ministre
êtes vous prêt à prendre notamment ces
mesures merci monsieur manuel valls
ministre de l'intérieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur louis pour
réaliser l'union sacrée en matière de
lutte contre la délinquance et le crime
organisé
il faut partir des bons chiffres et en
tout cas nous pouvons nous mettre
d'accord sur un sujet c'est que
malheureusement la violence de notre
société progresse elle progresse depuis
longtemps qu'il s'agisse des violences
sur les personnes des crimes sexuels ou
infra familiaux ou tout simplement les
cambriolages en zone gendarmerie
et puis il faut comparer ce qui est
comparable mais ça je le dis en passant
en octobre 2011
les chiffres de la délinquance avait été
arrêté deux jours avant la fin du mois
ce qui explique qu'un an après il y
avait évidemment des reports qui peuvent
donner l'explication que vous cherchez
sur l'augmentation que vous soulignez
mais moi je ne veux pas polémiquer sur
les chiffres car ce qui m'intéresse
c'est un l'activité de la police et de
la gendarmerie
et deuxièmement c'est capacité des
forces de l'ordre à combattre la
délinquance et pour cela avant de
réaliser l'union
sacré il fallait arrêter de détruire les
postes de policiers de gendarmes comme
ça a été le cas au cours de ces
dernières années
dix mille postes 3000 supplémentaire
était prévue en 2013
nous faisons le choix contraire et nous
créons des postes de policiers et de
gendarmes à partir de 2013 tous les ans
500 parce que nous avons besoin
les forces de l'ordre ont besoin de
postes supplémentaires même si ça n'est
pas suffisant qu'il faut évidemment
travailler sur l'émission parce que
c'est là le plus essentiel et s'attaquer
aux vrais résultats
s'attaquer aux causes de cette
délinquance le crime organisé les
violences sur les personnes
le trafic de drogue et d'armes les
cambriolages les arrachages de colliers
d'or parce que nos concitoyens vous avez
raison nous attendent évidemment sur ces
sujets là et je veux dire ma
détermination que ce soit l'état d'abord
et l'état d'abord qui assure la lutte
contre la délinquance et la sécurité de
nos concitoyens
enfin bien évidemment il y a une force
inégalement répartie sur notre
territoire
les polices municipales vous l'avez
rappelé moi même j'étais maire de
banlieue à evry en ile de france il y a
une police municipale
cette police municipale elle est
complémentaire du travail que la police
et la gendarmerie réalise vos collègues
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
rené vandierendonck et françois pinet
ont réalisé un rapport d'une très grande
qualité sur les missions des polices
municipales
nous allons nous en inspirer nous allons
réunir l'ensemble des représentants des
policiers municipaux mais aussi les élus
concernés pour avancer dans ce sens
parce que la police municipale mérite
tout notre respect et d'être intégré
dans la lutte contre l'insécurité
merci monsieur marc laménie pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les ministres
ma question s'adresse à monsieur manuel
valls ministre de l'intérieur sur le
ministre le 15 novembre dernier
madame marie
le brochure annoncé qu'en 2020 et les
agglomérations les plus grandes éliront
leurs représentants intercommunaux au
suffrage universel direct dès le mois
d'octobre vous même ne lisiez vous pas
entrevoir une autre perspective au sénat
devant la délégation aux collectivités
territoriales et à la décentralisation
tout en étant cependant moins précis
vous avez dit le fléchage est une étape
de démocratisation il n'en perd pas
l'avenir
la prochaine loi de décentralisation
inclure un nouveau statut pour les
internes en intercommunalité le plus
grande
ne lancez vous pas cette semaine des
concertations en vue du dépôt d'un
prochain texte sur les modes de scrutin
l'élection en 2014 des délégués
communautaires a occupé une bonne partie
du premier débat du congrès des maires
mardi consacrée à la nouvelle étape de
la décentralisation
la preuve que c'est un sujet
particulièrement sensible pour les
maires notamment des petites communes
que la prudence relative des propos des
membres du gouvernement à ce congrès et
de monsieur le président de la
république lui-même ne rassure pas
vraiment le président de la république a
certes confirmé les prêts si les
principaux engagements qu'il avait
formulées le 5 octobre dernier dans le
cadre des états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale organisé par le
sénat et notamment sa préférence pour le
modèle du fléchage pour l'élection des
délégués communautaires
une histoire de contrat de confiance à
tisser avec les élus qui semble encore
relativement lointain souvenons nous que
lors de l'examen de la réforme
territoriale qui est mis en place
le fléchage des craintes s'étaient fait
jour sur les bancs à gauche de cet
hémicycle malgré les garanties apportées
au motif que la légitimité des mères
seraient diminués estompant
inévitablement le rôle des communes
légitime et donc la crainte des élus de
proximité qui se dévouent au quotidien
qu'avec les réformes annoncées les
petites communes et à souffrir d'un
autre mode d'élection des délégués
intercommunaux
monsieur le ministre quelle assurance
pouvez vous nous donner qu'il n'en sera
rien je remercie aussi le seul manuel
valls ministre l'intérieur
le président monsieur le sénateur marc
laménie pourquoi avoir les inquiétudes
ou créer des problèmes là où il n'y en a
pas vous parlez de 2020 parlons d'abord
de 2014 le président de la république et
le premier ministre m'ont chargé de
préparer un texte de loi et de mener une
console une consultation une
concertation avec les formations
politiques et les groupes représentés au
parlement
elle est en train d'avoir lieu bien
évidemment il s'agit à la fois de
discuter des dates des prochains
scrutins suite à l'abrogation du
conseiller territorial de définir le
futur mode de scrutin pour les conseils
généraux
et puis enfin de traiter la question de
l'intercommunalité
je veux dire que l'intercommunalité a
été une des étapes de
l'approfondissement de notre démocratie
locale et de l'organisation de nos
territoires et nous devons évidemment à
jean pierre chevènement et à dominique
voynet que n'at-on pas entendu il ya
quelques années sur ces questions alors
que progressivement la carte
intercommunale est en train de s'achever
vu les responsabilités de nos
agglomérations et de nos communautés de
communes
il est au fond assez logique que la
question démocratique se pose celle du
suffrage universel
elle se posera incontestablement mais
avant d'en arriver là il s'agit de mieux
définir les projets de rendre plus
lisible plus visible l'action de
l'intercommunalité pour nos concitoyens
et je le sentiment qu'il y à un accord
très large concernant ce qu'on appelle
le fléchage nous y travaillons un texte
de loi devrait après cette concertation
est présenté au conseil des ministres et
le sénat d'abord en seraient saisis au
mois de janvier
au début de l'année 2013 comme c'est
prévu bien évidemment monsieur le
président larcher je commence à
connaître la constitution j'ai besoin de
vos conseils sur bien des sujets mais
pas surtout en tout cas là dessus nous
aurons l'occasion d'y travailler et nous
pourrons ainsi faire avancer la cause de
l'intercommunalité
à travers ce fléchage et au fond il
s'agit de garder tout son rôle à la
commune parce que il ya un attachement
de nous
concitoyens c'est évident et
progressivement en même temps de mieux
définir les missions de
l'intercommunalité et les élus qui
siègent avec une autre idée que le
fléchage permettra c'est la parité la
parité qui doit s'imposer aussi dans nos
intercommunalités comme dans l'ordre
exécutif voilà monsieur le sénateur les
éléments que je pouvais vous apporter
merci dernière question monsieur yannick
vaugrenard pour le groupe socialiste
apparentés
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre delphine
batho monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues depuis l'extension de l'europe
vers l'est
le centre de gravité du continent ce
sont les trouver bouleversée et justifie
encore plus aujourd'hui qu'hier un
développement équilibré de notre
territoire national dans ce contexte
l'ouest a besoin de tgv d'autoroute d'un
grand port mais aussi d'un grand
aéroport performant et sécurisé en
source d'accompagnement et de
développement économique en 2012 dans un
contexte pourtant difficile
toutes les prévisions d'augmentation de
transport de voyageurs de l'aéroport de
nantes atlantique ont été dépassées et
le situe au premier rang français en
termes de croissance en 2010 est à son
ouverture
l'aéroport de notre-dame-des-landes
accueillera ainsi plus de 4 millions de
passagers
le transfert de l'aéroport actuel
s'appuiera sur la grande région ouest et
devrait en accueillir 9 millions à
l'horizon 2050
ce projet qui date de plus de 30 ans a
traversé tous les processus juridique
prévu la consultation et la concertation
ont eu lieu de juste indemnisation aux
expropriations sont actés bref la
démocratie pleine et entière s'est
exercé les élus des régions départements
et communes concernées soutiennent
ultra-majoritairement ce transfert qui
profitera à tout le grand ouest et pour
votre information par ailleurs eva joly
candidate aux présidentielles et
opposante emblématique à cette
implantation
à réaliser sur cette circonscription
2,83 % le temps est donc venu de dire
juridiquement et politiquement à
quelques activistes
ça suffit voir des parlementaires
chargés de faire la loi et une candidate
ayant prétendu aux plus hautes fonctions
de l'état et anciennement juge faire le
coup de force est affligeant il est
ahurissant que les élus de la république
se lance dans de telles provocations
susceptibles de générer à nouveau de
l'attention alors qu'il devrait être
plutôt soucieux d' exemplarité la
désobéissance civile
un sens dans un état non démocratique
elle est condamnable dans un état de
droit et nous sommes dans un état de
droit
pouvez vous n'aurez affirmé monsieur le
ministre la détermination du
gouvernement et nous rappeler
l'échéancier de la construction de ce
nouvel aéroport
il est en effet de notre responsabilité
de préparer l'avenir
nous entendons garder notre destin en
main et continuer à assurer le
développement notre territoire
tout autant que le respect qui est dû à
la démocratie merci ma parole et à
monsieur stéphane le foll ministres
d'agriculture
le président messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur vaugrenard c'est
une question évidemment concerne
directement l'agriculture puisque les
exploitations agricoles sont concernés
par ce projet vous avez évoqué dans
votre propos beaucoup de choses je pense
que tout projet d'infrastructure suscite
des gisements des questions et souvent
des oppositions chacun dans son
département sur des infrastructures
routières ferroviaires ou d'autres
d'ailleurs a connu évidemment des
mobilisations qui conteste ces grandes
infrastructures et il faut rester
justement monsieur sénateurs dans l'état
de droit et faire en sorte que dans ce
débat nous soyons capables tous deux
dépassé ces oppositions et quelquefois
ses passions il faut guère rester vous
l'avait dit et je le partage sur
l'intérêt général l'objectif qui visait
pas simplement sur les conditions dans
lesquelles ça peut se mettre en oeuvre
quel est l'intérêt général de ce projet
pourquoi et vous l'avez dit l'aéroport
de nantes aujourd'hui voit son trafic
augmenter
pourquoi entre nantes et rennes entre
deux grandes régions la bretagne et les
pays de loire qui sont les plus belles
vous le savez ici bien sûr au sénat non
je le dis pour provoquer mais je veux ça
ne réagit pas il y a besoin d'avoir des
infrastructures de s'ouvrir à la fois au
niveau de l'europe et aussi à
l'international a le sens du projet et
moi je reste avec le gouvernement sur le
sens du projet il faut que dans l'état
de droit bien sûr toutes les procédures
sont respectées que les débats
contradictoires soit respectée et c'est
été le cas et il faut que ça continue
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement agit avec
cet objectif le sens de l'intérêt
général
l'objectif aussi de prendre en compte
l'intérêt de ces régions de l'ouest et
de faire en sorte que au travers de cet
aéroport
il y est un outil de développement
supplémentaire
merci chers collègues nous en avons
finir et des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h15 pour la
discussion du projet de loi de finances
pour 2013